go here in the opening quarter
and a steal by butler stepping in front
of giannis and he slams it on the other
end
rotating the ball play picked off by
butler here he'll go
galloping the other way and hammer it
home their turn over here early for the
pucks
jimmy butler out races here
13 assists to career high form in game
two then with the seal down the other
end they throw it ahead to butler and
butler throws it down
i know that your defense creates some
offense here
the deflection from behind butler and
adebayo down low off the ring looking
for him but the pass outside for crowder
and he got the three
look at this pass here by jimmy butler
to a wide open crowder
guarded by brondon here
gets into the paint and draws the foul
and
it jimmy buckets jimmy butler a tough
two maker
and a steal by butler stepping in front
of giannis and he slams it on the other
end
get in passing lanes to create
deflections
he makes the deflection with the lead
hand the right hand so no
foul
[Applause]
butler three on the way got it jimmy
buckets
splash down and the heat take a
one-point lead
jimmy butler these are the moments that
he cherishes these are the moments that
he's used to and loves
butler downhill on tatum into traffic
got it
and one clutch time dave county
jimmy butler delivering he is relentless
gets the angle and the step
on tatum butler says give me the ball
butler the drive the runner he banks it
in oh what a masterpiece from jimmy
butler
just gets marked morris back paddling
takes a bump and finishes it
[Music]
like he's not putting any pressure on
miami oh
what a shot by jimmy butler
look at this desperation shot here i'm
just trying to
put it on the rim he thought he was
going to get the call here
pass deflected by butler tries to save
it and it finds its way to robinson
down to butler and butler throws it down
it's back to a one-point game we see
what mark talked about
that length and the hustle what up it's
your boy adam lefkow did you like that
content i know you like that content hit
subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report